I I think uh a lot of people would have
an issue with what you're saying Neil is
because they see women being denied
opportunities they see an unfair playing
field metaphorically and literally
speaking so fix the playing field damn
it what don't don't say it's an unfair
playing field so all of a sudden the big
issue is trans women taking the slot of
a woman in an unfair playing field fix
the playing field and you know something
the day you fix that playing field this
conversation will look completely
ridiculous so how do you fix the playing
field I'm curious well that's hard it's
it's hard we've been
through thank you for that question I
think look if you're advancing that a
solution I think I have a right to ask
you no it's great I don't have a fast
solution this idea of an unfair playing
field yes we all agree there is an
unfair playing field biological boys
should not be wrestling or dunking over
uh chicks like that's just the thing